yeah I think there are interesting
reasons why so much money is being spent
on AIDS first of all I think it's
appropriate I mean it's an enormous
global problem that causes tremendous
amount of disease and death and we
should respond to that so so I think
just on the face of it it's it deserves
the funny it gets but there's an
important lesson I think to be learned
from AIDS funding AIDS was not getting
so much attention until advocacy started
and some very passionate smart committed
people started to do advocacy on behalf
of patients with HIV took all sorts of
tactics some extreme maybe people would
say disrupted meetings barged into
offices of legislators but ultimately
they were heard and I've gotten to know
many of these people they're very smart
they're very well-informed they
understand the science but they
represent people who are suffering and
those people understood how to use their
economic power their political power
their access to the media to get their
message across other groups have learned
that women with breast cancer have
learned that so women with breast cancer
I've organized not just to have walks in
Central Park but how to lobby their
congressmen and vote to get things
supported that they need support for the
TV community is way behind in all of
those advocacy efforts now part of it is
because unlike the HIV community where
you had successful educated men with HIV
infection who are prominent in all sorts
of areas in society unlike breast cancer
we have successful sophisticated women
who know how to get access to the median
to politicians TB has not really had
that I mean TV really in the United
States now is largely a disease of
rinse many of whom don't speak English
many of whom are probably not here
legally it's a disease poor people of
uneducated people who don't have that
kind of sophistication and access so
we've lagged far behind I think we're
starting to catch up but I think that's
one of the reasons we've fallen way
behind other important diseases yes the
government needs to do more the US
government earmarks relatively little
money for tuberculosis every once in a
while something happens in the media and
politicians in Washington pay attention
and we hope that they pay attention long
enough to get some bill ram through last
summer everybody was aware of this guy
flying around the world who had some
kind of drug-resistant TB and Congress
paid a lot of attention and they were
hearing held hearings held and and some
bills to increase money for TB treatment
and TB research moved a little further
along in the Congress they've been
sitting there for years so that got a
lot of attention and pushed the ball a
little further down the street but not
quite into the goalies net I guess you
would say